hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 10
video so we got a couple really big
comic book moments so I'm gonna explain
those first and then I'll get it a top
five moments just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet so
starting with the new character the
person we met at the end was Aaron he's
directly from the comic books he's part
of the Alexandria safe zone storyline
it's his job to scout new recruits for
the safe zone to go out and like follow
them around see if they're not complete
psychos and then bring them back so it's
a really big deal that they're
introducing him this soon the second big
moment was Rick said we are The Walking
Dead probably his most famous comic book
quote that was from issue 24 during the
heart's desire storyline the context in
which he said it was very different but
the matically it did what it did work
with what was going on in this episode
in the comic he had been passed out for
a long time and the group didn't know if
he's gonna wake up they were losing
faith in him but eventually he woke up
and it's kind of a reaffirmation of his
desire to survive he said we are The
Walking Dead the way he said it in this
episode was a lot less climactic and it
came before that big storm smash cut at
the end with the walkers trying to pound
their way into the barn did you get the
idea it's just a reaffirmation of their
will to live okay so getting into top
five moments here we go number five
everyone is losing the will to live
slowly it's kind of like everyone wants
to just lay down in the road and die the
way they're just kind of shuffling down
the road makes them look like walkers
themselves Maggie
Sasha and Daryl look like they're
getting ready to go off the deep end it
takes in most of the episode but but
eventually they open up they start
talking if it seems a little weird
because it was so quiet it's just that
they want you to fill the episode with
your own emotions like they want you to
feel what these characters are feeling
so by making it that quiet it forces
your own brain to conjure up whatever
you think that they're feeling and it
ends up being that much more emotional
I'm always interested to see how
different each of the Walking Dead
episodes are cut the way that they edit
each of them like last week we had that
weird intro this week we started with a
close-up of Maggie's eyes I do have to
give them props for trying so hard to do
different things you guys can let me
know whether you thought all this
silence was effective did it put you
into their mind space Daryl Maggie and
Sasha moving on to number 4 the bridge
Massacre this is the first moment that
shocks them out of the funk like oh god
we got to deal with this now
it's one of the few times in the episode
when there actually is a music cue and
you go from like dead silence like a lot
of dead silence
to this crazy anxiety-inducing hans
zimmer tune i feel like because the
episode was so silent these music hues
like this to drive all the tension even
when we got the storm it's like the
music is doing most of the work is
anyone having fun watching Sasha go a
little bit crazy I mean everyone's a
little bit crazy right now but but she
is going hardcore even me Sean tells her
to chill out later in the episode Daryl
and Maggie are like she's tough just
like Tyreese was but you really see in
moments like this when Sasha starts to
go a little nuts
she really is cut from the same cloth as
Tyreese it's like when Tyreese was
talking about himself the time he walked
into the herd of walkers with the knife
like he wanted them to just overwhelm
him Maggie had kind of that same moment
to where that Walker almost crawled on
top of her before if she killed it I'm
gonna think of that as Walker assisted
suicide and speaking of which you
remember when Daryl went out into the
woods and he saw that Walker sitting up
against the tree that looked like it
might have committed suicide and then he
sat down with the cigarette later in the
episode in that same pose thankfully
they pulled him back from that I mean
after he put the cigarette out on his
hand he started to cry sir - finally
process the emotions and then cue the
giant rain storm as if the world is
crying with him moving on to number
three
biblical rain storm comes to wash their
problems away
did anyone else pick up on a subtle
religious theme going through the
episode almost like a Noah's Ark
situation since Herschel's been gone
they haven't gotten too heavy with
religion but Gabriel's still there and
at least until halfway through the
episode when he takes his frock off they
do invoke some literal religious
interpretations
Maggie's like I know exactly what that
is my father was very religious just the
idea of a suit made of hair sounds so
creepy I actually liked the scene in the
bar more than I liked the bridge
massacre just because Carl had put baby
Judith down it looked like they weren't
gonna survive look like the walkers were
gonna overpower them and then it just
cuts to the next morning you have no
idea what happened until it cuts over to
Rick with baby Judith in his arms I
liked that they didn't make us wait to
find out did anybody else just freak out
a little bit when Carl put baby Judith
down by herself I was like ooh that is
how babies get stolen right there the
title of the episode was them so I kept
waiting for them to show up which I
think became literal once Erin showed up
the them representing the Alexandria
save zone people moving that's number
two we are The Walking Dead like I said
awesome comic book moment that they
finally paid off in the episode though I
love Rick's story about his grandpa
refusing to tell him about killing
people but totally spilling the beans on
the dark story about how he woke up
everyday thinking he was already dead
the argument that he gets into with me
shown is is that this apocalypse that
they're living in
Michonne thinks this isn't real life
this is just a bad dream that's gonna go
away eventually Rick and a couple of the
others disagree but you know they say
this is reality we have to learn to deal
with it we have to learn to grow up let
me know if you agree do you think that
Karl as a child who's still growing up
is better suited to adapt to life in the
apocalypse than the adults it's like
that Star Wars thing you're too old to
begin the Jedi training it's too hard
for you to unlearn what you've already
learned I guess if you took the idea to
its logical conclusion it's really baby
Judith that's the one that's best suited
to survive oh and one more fun fact
about that we are the walking dead line
in the comics if each of this really
tender Carol Rick kiss which I think is
kind of funny because we the nice moment
with Carol patting Daryl on the head
earlier in the episode based on how
fried Daryl is right now I would say
that's about as close as he's gonna get
with anyone this season and my number
one moment
meet Aaron it was so funny how creepy he
just he walked into frame hello stranger
danger like he was literally calling
himself out as creepy and then the music
box turns on it was such a perfect crazy
ending to a crazy episode so like I said
he is the beginning of the Alexandria
safe zone storyline it doesn't mean
they're gonna get there in the next
episode they said that they're about 60
miles out I assume that's from
Washington DC I have no idea how close
they're gonna keep it to the comic books
whenever we do get there we can just
compare with the comic books and see
what they've cut out what they've
changed but Aaron's job is just to make
sure that they're not complete psychos
before he brings them back to the safe
zone I'll be really interested to see if
they go to the safe zone like right away
and we spend a bunch of episodes there
it completely changes my ideas about the
season normally you think they'd save a
big payoff moment like that for the end
of the season so he might just stay with
them for a while to get a sense for who
they are but it seems like he kind of
already does let me know though what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and do you think that they're going to
be going to the Alexandria safe zone in
the next episode or do you think they're
gonna wait a couple more weeks it seems
like just based on the episode
descriptions for the next couple of
episodes they're not gonna be going
there right away
but all in all a very weird but good
episode I think it was weird in a good
way
it just sometimes it can be
or anything when the style changes from
episode to episode so quickly that's
what you call em Ebates right there
usually you see shows try really
cinematic techniques like this whenever
they're trying to win awards and I think
that is one of AMC's big goals they want
Walking Dead to win awards not only is
it the most popular show in the world
they want it to be the most critically
successful show in the world - whether
or not that actually ends up happening
as much as they shoot the show in a very
rural setting usually they're walking
around the woods somewhere they really
try to inject a lot of creativity and
artistry into it so I do give them high
fives for that is it doesn't always work
I mean it was a little bit weird with
just how quiet it got but I think it
worked with the story they were trying
to tell in this episode the survivors
are slowly turning into walkers
themselves they're just slowly giving up
the will to live until an act of God
comes and shakes them out of their funk
I'm interested to see if that restored
Gabriel's faith it seems like he kind of
lost it in the episode when he burned
his frock so really the biggest thing to
get excited about is this new errant
character and to see how he changes the
dynamic especially the next couple of
episodes it seems like we're gonna spend
some time with them before we get to the
Alexandria safe zone so be sure to
subscribe to get next week's video I
know there's the Oscars but they're
still airing Walking Dead so I'm totally
gonna do Walking Dead don't forget
there's a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so I'll announce the winner
whenever I post my Q&A video tomorrow
while you guys wait for that you can
click here for last week's episode of
The Walking Dead and you can click here
for my latest Game of Thrones Season 5
video thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five
we are The Walking Dead